no because it just looks bad
so we like to present ourselves properly
so are
but basically guys i saw these headlines
and i think smile to general proposition
sent me something as well one of his
videos i'm mistaken
and i said to myself this is actually
really pathetic you know it's actually
not forget prophetic this is actually
crazy
not it's not fair it's crazy how are you
calling a
dead baby a jihadi baby this is
absolutely
mad so i thought you know what let me go
to the office i tried calling them
i tried email i thought you know what
let me go
to the office yeah and talk to this
person yeah because i went on his
twitter it doesn't seem like an
islamophobe
so what why enough would he say such a
thing
so we're gonna head there you're gonna
see the footages now i had my camera
inside the building as well we went
there to speak to daniel
and ask him some questions of how a dead
baby
is a jihadi baby do you even know what
jihad means
but anyways we went there to ask some
questions
yeah um and it had to be done these
things have to be done because the more
we brush and think oh it's okay
believe me things will escalate and they
are escalating
we need to put a stop to this if we
don't
our children are going to suffer we're
going to suffer islamophobic attacks
islamophobia is on the rise and they
these cows always attack
sisters and elderly men you know we get
their threats ourselves
so let's put a stop to this we went
there let's see
what happened so brother sisters we are
going to
metro office head office we came here
by the daily mail thing about three four
years ago
i think it's the same address so we're
going there we've emailed them gonna
wait for a response
he wants to talk to daniel bintz his
name is daniel bins
so he's made this article this uh report
on the metro uh where he's titled
the video the the article
jihadi baby yeah so i thought maybe he's
quoting somebody because it does say in
the title
that this other person uh said this but
when i read it he didn't say that
so he's labeled it jihadi baby so we
just want to find out how does a baby
become a jihadi
and hold on a second even you can't have
a baby jihadi but
the term jihadi yeah do you even know
what jihad
is do you even know what it is and in
your context it's
a terrorist yeah now this baby is a
terrorist so we're going to go and find
out we're going to go to the metro
office and find out how is a how does a
baby become a
jihadi and why would you use danny are
you trying to dehumanize babies now
now muslim adults okay yes you can
attack and kill them it's okay
now now go for the babies as well you
know not even the babies don't even have
sympathy for the babies
i've done a bit of research on him i'm
just going to go and find i want to
speak to him nothing aggressive i'm not
telling robin so i'm here to threaten
people
but i have a nice discussion show if we
can find him if not we want to ask some
questions
because we can't turn a blind eye to
these things if you turn a blind eye it
will get worse
and worse and worse and then you will
have uh black weapon in nazi germany the
nuremberg roads where
the jews were dehumanized let's find out
so
my
yes okay do you have an appointment sir
uh no i wanted to see
daniel bins do uh well daniel he's a
journalist
for the metro yeah have you an
appointment this is no i tried to get in
contact uh
my email i tried to call them right but
they didn't answer
well i didn't answer the phone or didn't
answer the email they didn't answer the
phone
and i emailed them is what they didn't
ask for right yeah i just want to ask a
question about an
article that was published about i think
yesterday was yesterday yeah
right and what does the nature of the uh
basically um
it's it's about the another dog who's
traumatized them
there's a baby that died yes yes okay
well i'll tell you what this situation
is uh nobody comes down to see
anybody without an appointment oh okay
so and that's uh
i'll tell you where that comes from from
uh charlie hudu
in paris four or five years ago and they
slaughtered
12 people so ever since then we've taken
all the signs down
same for the daily tablecraft same for
the sun all the other newspapers
and they always they will have a rule
nurse sorry
they have a rule where they don't see
anybody yeah unless there's an
appointment
so what we can do now is give you an
other number for you to ring
for you to begin this process again okay
because clearly
they have a telephone number they also
have emails and
uh they should be responding yeah so so
okay
to try and uh speak to daniel who is a
journalist
now do you know him i know i know
personally
well yes
i know them all okay i was just curious
because the thing is
i wanted to just ask him some questions
regarding um you know this article that
he's written
where it's talking about um jihadi baby
so i just wanted to ask him how a baby
becomes a japanese because i was very
very curious
how a baby an innocent baby that's died
becomes a jihadi
i don't know if you guys know do you
guys know do you know him
they're not they wouldn't answer that do
you believe that baby from the comments
i'm so i'm very curious and they
wouldn't answer that question do you
believe that
we wouldn't be prepared to get into that
confidence
between you
okay so let's get to the point now
because i don't want to be veering off
now if you would not lean on the
character that would help
thank you no because it just looks bad
so we like to present ourselves properly
so are you kidding me yeah
what you need well that maybe it will be
but i find that very disrespectful
i find that very disrespectful yes
now now okay listen my friends if you
will cooperation
i'm happy to give it if you want
cooperation that's fine
this is an elderly gentleman and there
might be some reason for that i don't
know
this is just arrogance that's what that
is
please thank you now let us focus on
what you need
um at this moment of time i've literally
done this
he's talking to me and i've done this
i'm just like my my elbow is
literally literally there i'm listening
then he hasn't got me for having my
elbow there okay i
assume the best about the charlie hebdo
thing he meant i don't know why he had
to bring that up here
so my elbow was literally like this i
swear to god i'm not even like this
i'm literally my elbow is down i'm
listening to him like okay i understand
sir
so then i turn around and i see an
elderly man he's got his hand like this
yeah he's got his hand like this yeah i
said okay what about him
yeah and he said it's elderly no problem
no valid point body point elderly
no problem then i see him you can see on
camera after this you can see very
clearly
he's got his own hand on there
anyways anyways this is i don't want to
be petty i don't want to be petty
anyways yeah i just want to let you guys
know exactly
where my elbow was and that caused me to
be an arrogant man
do we have a contact number for the
metro
yeah just give me the contact that's
what i need
the elbow i caught i caught you
i can write it here if you want um
instead of
email yeah but it's not a general email
which they'll pick up which danny will
be able to pick up
they won't give you daniel's email the
only person that can give you that will
be daniel
okay yeah so that's that give them a
call and you may be able to get in touch
with him at some time later today
yeah but it's a very busy day i'm sure
you can imagine because we've got this
brexit vote this evening
so most of our journeys are actually
down at parliament waiting for the
results to come through this evening if
you seem to ask that question
yeah maybe every day but maybe not today
sorry about
it
so basically guys we went in it was
quite interesting actually
um went in to speak to daniel he wasn't
here
and funnily enough uh maybe it was a
valid reason maybe
he said that this charlie hebdo attacks
happened and therefore they can't have
any journalists coming down
i don't know if he said that because of
the way i look or if it was a genuine
concern
but i'll assume the best uh so i went
there who said that if i can contact
them
so i'm going to get in contact with
daniel and ask him some questions of how
a
baby becomes a child a dead baby how a
dead baby
is a jihadi baby each other and charlie
can respond if not we will come and try
to visit him again
we've tweeted him on twitter please do
the same on twitter wherever he is
email him at the screen you can see here
the description box
and asking the question how does a baby
become a jihadi